[Music]
on today's show we talked to a father
whose ex-wife is dating somebody with a
history of domestic abuse and he wants
to know what to do next we take your
letters we talk about gratitude and some
new research has come out we talked to a
woman who is dating a guitar shredding
peter pan stay tuned
[Music]
yo yo what's up this is john with the dr
john deloney show
so glad you're with us
bringing some positivity in joy and
honesty and sadness whatever we're
bringing to the world on the show we
talk about mental health relationships
connection communication what's going on
in this crazy mess education anything
you want to talk about give me a shout
at 1-844-693-3291
that's
1-844-693-3291 or go to johndaloni.com
ask and i've got just my desk as a wreck
man i got shenanigans everywhere um
what movie is that from shenanigans
shenanigans
oh my gosh did you all not see
superstars office space
office sp
you all are on friendship probation the
whole the whole whole the whole lot of
you
unbelievable don't know shenanigans all
right hey big moment james after 225
episodes
so we've come
to the
it's time to uh
retire the the walgreens headphones that
we should speaking of office space we
should go out in the parking lot and
bash them with a bat or something oh
that'd be incredible
yes actually i'm gonna hang on to these
the new ones that we bought
excellent
you ever
i'm trying to think of a non-graphic way
to explain this i'm not going to
my ears are one size
the
headphones that i shove in the ears
are different size
all i got to say is
dang gina
i got some p-a-i-n up in my head
but it's cool though james is like these
are fancy it's what you've been asking
for and you're right james well done
kind of a masochistic producer but it's
cool same team same dream one dream
whatever all right hey um we're gonna do
a couple things today we're gonna have
some calls we're gonna go through some
of these awesome letters that people
sent in one person here the uh granger
family from maryland has like a harry
potter wax seal
like some sorcerers or something that's
kind of awesome and um talk about some
gratitude stuff so let's get to the
phones let's go to steve in tampa hey
steve what's up
hey dr john how are you brother having
me oh man thank you thanks for calling
in what's up dude
well so the the issue is my
ex-wife and i we have two kids uh 50 50.
okay and she's she's dating a man with a
long and recent criminal history
of domestic violence
multiple women
not to mention robbery so
question is how do i handle this oh my
gosh man what have you tried
tried everything
i've tried
um her family
i've tried lawyers
i've talked to my therapist about it i
mean i even
i even offered to set her up with an
online dating profile just to show her
that she can do so much better yeah um
but nothing
how old are your kids
six or nine it's jeez louise man
is she at a place where she's bringing
this this
um
idiot around them
oh yeah i mean they're they're on the
verge they're probably gonna get married
soon
okay what was your give me a couple of
the
some of the advice you received would
your counselor say
uh she had a good suggestion to create
um like a safe like a password for the
kids like an emergency
um
it's like a safe word like if they ever
just need me to come pick them up no
questions asked that is a hundred
percent
that'd be my number one thing that's
excellent or that'd be my number two
thing what else um did she recommend
um i think that was the big one um
i mean there's you know at this point
there's nothing that occurring is not
going to get changed and that's not
that's not my my role what did the
attorney say about my concern
i talked to four attorneys and they all
said there's nothing that i can do you
gotta wait till something happens
yeah it's all reactive
um that even in the extreme case of like
if he was a convicted child molester
that there's
that would be even a stretch
like none of them gave me a legal path
forward
wow
unbelievable
um
i'm just i'm thinking i'm putting myself
in your situation our kids are
relatively the same age
and there's nothing
nothing more important to me than the
safety and security of my kids both
psychologically physically
all that right
and so i'm just sitting here
not as a as a podcast guy or radio guy
but just as dad to dad man and
that feeling of powerlessness
i'm aching with you that's what i'm
telling you i'm heartbroken with you
brother
um
how are you doing how are you feeling
before i start running my mouth
here oh it's so it's like you said it's
just powerlessness um
i mean i know there's things i can't
control i know that i can't
prevent uh i can't keep them safe from
every danger out there but this just
seems
this just seems imminent and i'm just
supposed to just
take it accept it yeah yeah that's
that's a tough pill to swallow
is your wife interested in
does she like the joint custody
arrangement is this a power move for her
um
well played
you know
that's a whole different rabbit hole
there's probably going to be some
revisiting of that down the road like if
you went to her today and said i'm
willing to take 100 percent take these
these burdens from you and you can go
live your life would she say great or
would it be more of a how dare you
it would be hard area okay all right
okay
oh man all right so here's where i'm
starting if i'm you
number one
i'm gonna deal with i want to deal with
you internally
and also
then transition to the limited resources
that you have okay
number one dealing with you
is being constantly aware and i'm glad
you're seeing somebody you got to get
some buddies in your life
but being constantly aware
of the feeling of powerlessness because
that comes out in us differently there's
genetics there's there's the models we
grew up with there's all kinds of ways
that comes out but for some of us
powerlessness comes out in depression
some of us comes out in anxiety some of
it comes out in rage and anger and we
snap or we just fume some of it we end
up becoming addicted to scrolling so
think about what's happening you know
nationally internationally with the
coveted stuff right that feeling of
powerlessness comes out of of us in all
these rando ways and none of them are
helpful
right
and so it's constantly knowing okay now
i've found myself in a situation where
my body is sensing is not in control
here's what i'm going to do about it
okay so that's that's an important thing
is keeping yourself well in this process
and not letting yourself get down a hole
does that make sense
yeah okay
so here's number two i think your
counselor is way on to something and i
would recommend going one step further
so
you you've you listened to the show ever
you know i am radically
radically against phones for kids
um i think those things are i think they
are destructive there's not a redeeming
quality about a kid with a cell phone
none
and in your case i think it might be
worth visiting
getting them some sort of connective
device whether that's the um the
gabaphones is that the ones that that
have some sort of protective they don't
just open up the internet to a
seven-year-old right
but there's got to be some connection
between you and your kids
that then allows them to have some sort
of safe text safe word safe calls a safe
way to communicate with you
maybe even a safe uh well seven's really
young to start recording people without
them knowing and i don't know your
state's laws but some way they can
connect with you do they have phones or
devices now
yeah they have devices okay all right
tablets all right so shame on you and
good for you all right
so um some way they can communicate with
you
that leads me to number two and i would
explore this with your counselor
but there has to be a reality check so
i'm
a hundred percent against speaking
negatively about like x's even when
they're bonkers even when they're
destructive
but that doesn't mean that we don't tell
the truth factually
okay
so i would have conversations with my
kids about
and this is a this is a good practice
regardless right
there are
scary people in the world and some of
them are scary because they're loud
some of them are scary because they hit
other people some of them are scary
right you see where i'm going and this
is going to be age appropriate share
don't scare but
we're gonna have a conversation with our
kids that there is scary people out in
the world and i'm gonna begin having
conversations about what do you do
how do we respond to this
and i want your kids to know they
respond by calling you they respond if
you're not available by calling 9-1-1
and be very explicit about
sometimes we get so scared that we don't
want to move
and that's really important that you
reach out to daddy then
sometimes we get so scared and somebody
says if you tell anybody you're in big
big trouble
or i'm gonna hurt somebody then you
really have to tell dad
you really have to tell me right and
having this conversation
is it's it's
um it's insane the fact that you're even
having to have this conversation right
um and that's where you find yourself
and so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna begin to teach our kids and have
conversations with their kids about this
in a less pathological example my kids
know we have a 9-1-1 rule
if we're at a store or if we're at a
restaurant and i look at my son and say
this is a 9-1-1 situation we need to go
he knows ask no questions
ask no don't look around we get up and
we walk out of the restaurant and that's
happened once
um and again this some of this is
because i grew up with a homicide
detective and a swat guy as a as a
father and i run around with
police officers in the middle of the
night dealing with tragedy so some of
this is me being paranoid paranoid right
but also i want to have a situation with
him that knows
we got to go now and not his normal why
i'm still eating my burger right and so
this is just an extension of that
conversation
an invite every time your kids come home
tell me about what you all did how was
it what were the good stuff what was the
what were the b w's what was the best
times what were the worst times
tell me about a time you were scared
tell me about a time you felt brave and
i want you to make that a part of the
regular rhythm of your conversation with
your kids and again this is insane that
you're having to do this right but we're
gonna have this regular rhythm of this
conversation so that not if but when
something happens
it's a part of your regular rhythm it's
not gonna be this weird new you know you
hear me talk about talking with your
kids about sex if you wait to have a big
don't dun dun hey kid sex talk it's
gonna be a disaster if you make talking
about sex a regular rhythm in your house
then when your kid asks a question it's
not weird it's just part of the
narrative it's just part of the
interaction in your home same thing
we're doing here
um
but i want to have some sort of norm for
them calling you
is that fair
yes thank you um are you allowed and i
don't know the the laws in maryland are
you allowed to text your kids and check
in with them when they're with mom or do
you have to cut off communication
oh i'm allowed to communicate with them
anytime i want okay
so
um
i've had some interactions with folks
when they were going into meetings and
they were worried about safety and i've
sat outside their meeting
there was no threat or i've called
police officers to come sit outside of a
meeting when i was gonna have a
conversation with somebody that might be
volatile
um and we had things like
i'll just text you punctuation
i'll text you a question mark or a
period or a hyphen
and
it would it will look benign to anybody
else
but it might just be
you you say hey i'm just gonna start
texting you a couple of times you have
to respond
regardless and i'm gonna text you a
thumbs up and you're or that may be a
little bit on the nose but i'm gonna
text you an abc
and if everything's going great you text
me a def or whatever the thing is but
y'all come up with some sort of check-in
system
that would be benign and again we're not
talking about secrets and we're not
telling your kids all right we gotta do
this and not tell anybody
um
but just texting them hey i love you and
if things are going great say i love you
back and if they're not going great say
i love the astros or whatever the thing
happens to be right um how does that
sound
uh that sounds like a really good idea
okay thank you
um hey know that my heart's with you man
and
the moment something happens
please don't hesitate i know you won't
you've checked before lawyers you're
you're on top of a dad
don't hesitate
um sometimes there's some hesitation
like well that one wasn't that bad that
one wasn't this i don't want to blow
their lives up
mom is making a really um
damning decision here man and i'm sorry
you're in the middle of it and
it's just gonna require some extra
vigilance and making sure that you're
okay but uh man thank you so much for
your call brother and we'll be thinking
about you'll be with you man
and for those of you who
have an ex
and
you're
you're you're post-divorce and you're
dating
and you're with somebody and you think
man like this person's got these major
red flag flaws
but they love me and they've quote
unquote change whatever
be so
so careful about how you bring your kids
and into your life and end your life
kids lives
be very careful man
your kids deserve more than than you
being
with somebody who's an abuser
and quite frankly you deserve to be with
somebody who's more than abuser we'll be
right back on the dr john delaney's show
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john dolone show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john delaney show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
slash
betterhelp.com
all right we are back hey i got some
letters here from folks who have written
in
and
oh you know what this letter is from
maryland the last caller was from
florida man i screwed that up all right
um so i asked people to send in letters
about
what what are you looking forward to
this year like what do you think what
are some of the who you're gonna be this
year
and man i got a ton of letters keep them
coming i love getting mail i'm like a
middle schooler from the 70s even though
i wasn't a middle schooler in the 70s
not that old um
dude i love getting some of these this
person right
uh wrote dr john you realize it by
challenging us to write
we'll also let us call your bluff at
reading our mail checking back on our
resolutions right that was all in fun
you worked in higher ed consider that
the classic if you're reading this i
will buy you a candy bar uh okay so this
person's calling out there's been
professors
and i may have been one of them who
would tell you at the beginning of your
exam read the instructions before you
take this exam no kid reads the
instructions no student never reads
instructions they just dive right into
the exam and then i would put down on
question number 50.
answer no questions so put your name on
the top of this exam and turn it in and
people would have wrestled this thing
for two hours and fought all the way
through this exam or whatever and so
that's what they're talking about here
so gotcha there you go granger
calling your bluff here all right let's
see here's what uh granger says she
wants to be and i'm just using her last
name here
identity who are you gonna be in 2022
compassionate
active a good friend a 2 a.m kind of
friend
joyful helpful
someone who takes care of myself better
than i did previously so someone is a
steward of their heart and mind and body
body i'm going to start swimming i've
always wanted to i'm going to cut out
carbs and sugar every day i'm going to
walk and stretch
how there's a gym here at my work dude i
don't know where you work but that's
pretty rad
you don't do well with it you know you
don't feel good when you eat lots of
carbs and sugars and dude there's a
stretch app or yoga videos
excellent so you're saying here's who
i'm gonna be and you're breaking it down
into all right what does that mean i'm
gonna steward my body and then here's
here's how i'm gonna do it another one
is mind weekly meeting with myself dude
i like that just a weekly check-in 30
minutes you're worth 30 minutes a week
people 30 minutes a week that could be
journaling that could just be looking at
your calendar that can be looking at
your budget how am i doing right looking
at your exercise log
schedule class times for an online
master's program
that's outstanding outstanding go get
another degree good for you good for you
read fiction non-fiction books um pick
up declutter just take 30 minutes a day
to clean up your area all right said the
pot to the kettle as i look at my desk
and i look like
that's just a disaster here so excellent
excellent that's what i'm talking about
when it comes to who's your identity who
you're going to be and then how are you
going to backfill a plan how you going
to reverse engineer a plan that works
there here's another letter from looks
like the mountains in
colorado
let's see here ooh they wrote tiny
little little letters here
oh man let's see here
all right
um delony i'm pretty excited and nervous
to send you my goals for 2022 jumping
right into it i'm going to read 20 books
start financial coaching
um to waste less food
dude i like it start a garden
have our girls help with it the they're
almost three years old and then almost a
one-year-old
um get back to pre-pregnancy weight not
even gonna weigh in on that one because
then you'll cancel me the word um trying
to live by us confidence so this is the
identity i'm going to regain confidence
i've faked it for so long i want to take
steps to go outside my comfort zone to
help grow that confidence and how do you
get confidence
by
trying things practicing things getting
good at things and you only get good at
things by giving it a shot and doing it
again and again and again and again and
then you're going to fail you're going
to fail and then you're going to fail a
little bit less a little bit less and
you're going to have success and you're
going to go back to failing you're going
to go and go and go until you get
confidence a lot of us try to read our
way into confidence or chatter and run
our mouths into confidence unfortunately
you can't
you've got to do your way into
confidence you've got to go
and and get it done into confidence
and that's man we've got a culture we
just think our way into things and think
our way out of things let's discuss
let's talk just go do it just go do it
good for you good for you bailey
um this is my 2021 word that i want to
also continue with
hippie
sounds like james not in a woodstock way
more of a less wasteful less plastic
better products more local type of way
cool you're going to love locals my
buddy andy gullihorn says i love that i
love this idea of then covets for some
of us to do it
we just got to reengage locally like
what's my community doing how can i help
my community how can i get a business
going in this town how can i support
locally
i love love love that sentiment so
that's fantastic and along those lines
this article just came out in the wall
street journal
is the secret to happiness having a
gratitude practice
those of us who believe in being
grateful for things that go well duh
a surprising unifiers emerged over the
last year in the wall street journal my
monday morning column which chronicles
the routines and productivity secrets
people use to start their weeks
gratitude
stephen king does this actor tracy ellis
ross does this musical director
questlove does this
nike ceo john donahue spends time
meditating on questions like what am i
grateful for
it goes through actors and actresses you
know who else does this just regular
normal people
it doesn't have to be actors and ceos
just regular normal people
sit down and say hey listen
what is going good in my life our brains
are so wired to look for the negative to
keep us safe to protect us
that we have to practice sitting down
and going what am i grateful for now
i've practiced
being a gratitude i've had a gratitude
practice for years and years here's my
little journal right here it is i got my
uh stickers on it
by the way go ruck james i got my
backpack this isn't unsolicited we are
not paid by these folks we have no stake
in anything
james that goruck backpack
i i i know it sounds ridiculous to say
that it's a game changer it's a game
changer it's incredible do you like your
still
i love it but i feel like
it's so rugged that it's probably bored
like i feel like i want to go drag it
around behind my car to like give you
something you've personified your
backpack
i think that's your your uh
your your inner voice saying we should
probably just stop looking at computers
and go do something like that is that
what's happening yeah like it's probably
not made to you know carry laptops in
and out of office building
i love it dude so anyway is i i
for years written in this in this thing
um and i just get a new one every time i
fill it up there's some new science out
if you're not listening to um andrew
huberman's podcast it's so great he's a
medical school professor at stanford and
he's just a national treasure right now
um you can check it out i think it's the
hubermann lab podcast it's just
remarkable um and behind closed doors i
heard he's a great human being
um but he talks about some new science
about gratitude and instead of writing
down four or five things every day just
doing that over and over
it talks about the importance of letting
gratitude circulate throughout your body
and this idea of sitting down and
closing your eyes is very close to
meditation if you ask me
and remembering a time
a specific instance in your life when
you are grateful in letting your body
re-experience it
so instead of saying i'm grateful for my
wife i'm grateful for my kids i'm
grateful for food on the table et cetera
see i'm grateful for
the time my friend nathan
sat with me in the hospital when
my wife was having life forgiving i mean
life saving surgery
when a pregnancy went awry
a guy just sat with me
and i can remember my fear i can
remember my pain i can remember talking
with the
surgeon and knowing just crisis person
to crisis person this was dicey
and then out of nowhere my buddy nathan
who's a stoic he's a rancher he didn't
talk a lot
he just showed up and sat with me
and he just sat there and he just sat
there for a long time until he came and
got the news some of it was good so it
was bad
and
man i'm so grateful for his presence and
if i sit in that and let it wash over me
it's a powerful experience and that can
take one minute that can take two
minutes and so according to dr heberman
that's some of the new
um research about gratitude
so here's my challenge to you i don't
care if you're in the military i don't
care if you're a single mom i don't care
if you're a hard-charging ceo or you're
the assistant director of
you know the
janitorial staff at your office complex
i don't care what your job is
i care about you just as a person
this is a mom as a dad as a brother as a
husband as a son as a kid as a neighbor
as a community member as a
as a person
who lives in my country
spend a few minutes every day being
grateful
sit down close your eyes
remember a moment a time when you're
grateful somebody gave you a job
somebody reached out and extended a hand
somebody
put some money in your account when
you're broke
somebody came with a with a great idea
and said i want you to come along
somebody invited you into a meeting that
ultimately changed your life somebody
hired you and took a chance on you
somebody forgave you
right whatever it is sit down and just
feel that
feel it do it before your workout after
you work out before you go to bed
whenever
i'm gonna keep doing my gratitude i'm
gonna keep writing down five things i'm
grateful for every day i'm just gonna i
like the rhythm of that i've been doing
it for years but i have added this new
practice
and i can just tell you about nathan
just now i can feel it in my body
i can feel it
go for it be
grateful
and to you folks who are sending me
letters about your intentions
now we're into february we're getting
into march april
don't quit don't quit keep going keep
going keep going look back at the stuff
you wrote down in january and remember
the person you said you were gonna be
circumstances change life changes
relationships change
but you committed to being a new kind of
person stick with it stick with it with
action stick with it by challenging your
thoughts and changing your thoughts
stick with it by making sure you're
plugged into a community don't stop
having friends don't stop being
connected don't stop saying i'm sorry
don't stop saying i'm gonna do better
don't stop saying hey how can i make
this right
stay on it connection change your
thoughts change your actions be grateful
we'll be right back on the doctor john
williams show
y'all know there are lots of things that
make me nuts but one thing makes me more
nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you've got an expert in
a team who have your back listen if
you're about to buy a home and make a
big change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back let's go to sydney
in dayton ohio what's up sydney
good morning
sorry i
they told me to do a countdown off air
and
i was counting in spanish and then they
said that i shouldn't turn the mic on so
you got to hear me counting in spanish
that's what that was all about we're
helping out something new we're helping
out the youtube kids and i do like
spanish it's my favorite language all
right so what's up
so
i live with a guitar shredding peter pan
is his name james childs by any chance
no it's not all right just wondering
a guitar shredding peter band that's
that's my favorite
all right tell me about this
he
lives breathes sleeps eats guitar that
is all he he's incredible at today he's
incredible but that is all he is
interested in doing and that's all he
does
does he earn a living playing guitar
not really
no i am i have a very i take care of
everything well not everything is into
donald's he takes care of
he
he does make money he could he could be
professional
he just doesn't have the motivation i
take care of the house i own the house i
clean the house i repair the house i do
the car repairs
so how can i help
is there a way i can motivate him
what are you getting out of this
oh i have a blast with him he's sweet
he's affectionate
what else i've always taken care of
myself always okay i've always been
independent i have kept myself separate
financially
from everybody i've been with
you a lot of fun how old are you
old enough to know better
you're getting something out of this
what is it
companionship
why is this where you have landed
as your as your benchmark for
companionship
well it's not about him this is a story
about you
yeah
i lost someone after 13 years okay
pastor passed away
yeah
from addiction
and during that addiction i was totally
neglected for about eight years yep
and then after he passed
i met this one and he just
hugs me and holds my hand and pays
attention and loves me and shows it
and
that for your body
for your spirit that was worth the trade
for a season
yeah
living living eight years with an addict
you're is
it's like somebody
putting a plastic bag over your head you
can't breathe and then you're allowed
one one gulp of air you know every every
two minutes right you can't breathe for
eight years
and all of a sudden somebody takes that
bag off your head and
somebody comes up and just pumps oxygen
into you for a season right
and it feels so good
it sounds like you got a kid
you got a pet exactly
because you're a mom right now you're
not somebody's girlfriend
that is how i feel
that's what you are
yeah your feelings are accurate
often our feelings lie to us your
feelings are not lying
so you've got a child
that you take care of
and that offers you
sex intimacy and
human connection
what else
humor
yes i mean you can watch anchorman
reruns to get humor like what are they
what are they offering you
like you're getting something out of
this is it safety is it security is it
you can't fathom starting over yet again
like what what is it
no that doesn't scare me
yes it does
not really not starting over i love
change okay so break up with him today
well i don't want to hurt him
because he's not because he's your kid
yeah
now i was being facetious about breaking
up with him
that your response
confirms what you already know
your instant response was not but i love
him and i want to spend the rest of my
life with him it was now i'm trying to
protect him
and no relationship can be built on
protectionism like that
protection is a part of a relationship
but it comes from a deep-seated sense of
love and
interconnectedness
how long have you all been together
um
four years
you can tell me you're not afraid of
change
your body knows this story
the story of
lost the story of being single the story
of waking up and there's nobody next to
you your body knows that story and you
can tell me like nah it's cool man it's
not that's gonna be hard
be real real hard
is that true that is true yeah
i hate to admit that but that's true
one of the one of i mean there's so many
one of the great evils of living and
loving somebody who is
an addict
is you lose sense of yourself you feel
crazy every day
right
you feel you feel untethered you feel
disoriented just making your way through
the world because the person you love is
also the person that hurts you the most
and your body and your brain have to
toggle back and forth between
i'm in love and i care and i'm trying to
keep well
and i'm being hurt all the time either
through neglect
or positive right all the time
and
you feel bananas
and it can
lead to one of two things
hypercodependence
or
an addiction to absolute stoic control
you hit it no relationship can survive
either of those extremes
i fall in my life a little bit more on
the let's figure it out live woo
and my wife falls more on the
list-making side
like we have to have somebody that pays
the bills in this house john
and so there's there's there's degrees
here
but my guess is just listening to you if
you just you put your feet in concrete
on the control side i will control every
variable from this point forward to the
point that i'm gonna date
and be intimate with a child so i can be
that in control because part of you is
so terrified to risk love again
true
connected
partnership love
because with that risk comes great hurt
and you felt it
oh yeah
and the hard scary sucky part of love is
the only way it works is if you risk if
you go all in
otherwise you end up
sleeping with a
guitar shredding peter pan
right
and peter pan was a child
so you you knew calling this you knew
calling me
that you've got some hard decisions to
make what are you gonna do
i feel like i'm leading you and i don't
want to be leading you
right what are you gonna do
i really
it's eventually things are gonna have to
change so what i'm telling you is not
going to
i mean with myself ah there you go have
you sat down and said dude you got to
get a job
oh yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
well i ran a company for a few years and
i
am a recruiter
okay
and do you do well recruiting
oh yeah
yeah
i'm able to take care of myself
and him
but um
okay but you're wearing that as a badge
of honor
you have not dealt with being married
and in love with an addict have you
no
you haven't that that hurts way too much
to think about you have to deal with
that
the idea that your status your level of
success
is i can take care of myself
that that's the most fundamental like
that is
benchmark one to just being an adult
that's nothing to be said for i
experience joy
i actually have true laughter i've got
true relationships where i risk where i
love where i give and i take and i
disagree and i fight and i come back and
i love harder the next time like
you're still so wrapped
into your original pain
that j like i take care of myself yeah i
hope you do you're an adult yeah and
you're really freaking smart
and one of my closest people to me in
the world is a world-class recruiter and
you got to be real savvy and real smart
and very quick
and stay up late and get up early and
all those twists and turns of that job
and i know you can do that but you got a
blind spot here you haven't dealt with
the original pain why are you scared to
go in you say it's gonna hurt so bad why
i don't know i just
i've never felt anything like that i've
had loss
but
i tried so hard to keep him alive
and do everything i could
yeah his death is not on you
it feels like it you got to put that
story down sister
he didn't die because of you
it took me a long time to figure out i
couldn't do anything though in it while
i was in the throes of it
i tried everything of course you did
because i could think of it because you
loved him
but you still wake up every morning with
the feeling
with the brick in your backpack that you
killed your husband and that's not true
it's not true
that story doesn't hold water
it's a
myth and that brick is keeping you from
relationships that you deserve
from
joy and laughter that you deserve from
sleep
man you talk about people who can't
sleep be married to an addict
right oh yeah the fear all night long
all night long
yeah
you still don't sleep do you
nope i wake up every night a few times a
night
can i tell you you deserve to lay down
and go to sleep and sleep all night
you deserve somebody who will love you
and participate in
bills
participate in
what you want to do joy all that stuff
you got to set that brick down i want
you to say out loud
what was his name
the one that passed yep
chris
i want you to say out loud
i am not responsible for chris's death
i am not responsible for chris's death
you just said that in a very clinical
way i want you to drop your shoulders
all the way down you had to you had to
say it to get through it i get it i want
you to drop drop your shoulders all the
way down
drop them they're clenched up around
your ears right now i can feel it
drop them down
and say it
i'm not responsible for chris's death
i am not responsible for chris's death
and today before the day is over
you have one homework assignment
that's to call somebody and say
it's time for me to start healing
and my promise to you is this when you
start healing from that trauma that
you've experienced and you've been
through a lot
the death is big
the death is the big acute trauma but
you experienced so much you know this
cognitively your body's holding so much
pain
still
still vigilant still trying to keep
things going
so much so that it will take love from a
child just to keep some oxygen pumped
into your heart and just so you can keep
going
i want you to call a counselor and say
today's the day
make that first call i gotta start
healing
will you do that for you
i absolutely will you promise
i promise you're the bravest person i
will talk to this week
did you know what you're gonna have to
walk the the the harrowing hallway
you're gonna have to walk down to heal
this right
yeah a lot of tears i've been holding
back yeah man
think how exhausted your body is from
not wanting to feel for so long
from carrying that guilt and that weight
think about it as a backpack full of
bricks think how tired your body is
when you finally set that stuff down and
let that stuff go and let that stuff out
your
body you're gonna sleep oh my gosh
sister
and then
you'll look over and go what are you
doing in here man
peter
work or go
i'm freaking sydney from dayton
i'm not a mom
i'm a woman who's gonna have
a relationship that is
egalitarian we're gonna love each other
we're gonna support each other and we're
gonna run for the hills together
i'm not going to be anybody's mommy
unless i have my own children
that fair
that is fair
you're the bravest person to talk to
now here's the thing
you make that call and get an
appointment on the calendar and you your
your homework assignment is to
email me back and let me know i did it
okay cool
i will do that if you don't i'm gonna
publicly shame you i'm just kidding i'm
not gonna do that
okay
i promise i promise
you're worth
more than all of this
you're worth more than all of this
you got a heart sometimes i know huh
sometimes i know that
i know because you're smart
and you're
i guarantee you're a fun person you're
an exhausted person
anxious exhausted person
and you just deserve more than that
simply because you're my sister because
you live in my country you're my friend
you're breathing you're a person on
planet earth anything you want to throw
in there
[Music]
it's time to heal it's time to heal and
then get on to the next chapter that is
whatever you want to make it
[Music]
first step first step down the down the
track starts today so proud of you
sydney we'll be right back in the dr
john delaney show
big secret
almost all of us can control our
thoughts
yes you can control your thoughts you
choose them most people believe thoughts
randomly happen and that we have to give
rent-free space to bad thoughts and
scary thoughts and freaky thoughts this
is not true
our world doesn't want you to know this
because they want the privilege of
owning your mind no more i want to teach
you how to take back your thoughts
if you often find yourself lost in a
tornado of toxic thoughts and anxiety
and always on high alert you'll have to
be intentional about changing your
thoughts but it is 100 percent possible
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to mental health
and wellness that includes learning how
to reject harmful thoughts and cultivate
thoughts that move you closer to who you
want to be
and if you pre-order today you'll get
hundreds of dollars of free bonus items
so go to johndaloni.com to take the next
step towards wellness that's own your
past change your future at
johndaloni.com
all right hey we're back hey real quick
just in case we didn't know how awesome
sydney was in her email she listed out
the guitars that her boyfriend plays ooh
let's judge she said he plays the
japanese ibanez and eddie van halen
frankenstein guitar a flying v and a
hammer
which sounds right up your alley that's
that's even too far for me that sounds
like
a flying v absolutely if it's the gibson
flying v if it's the jackson flame v i
would for sure take it but i'm not gonna
pay for that the bc rich flying v the
carrie king one oh it's so rad i saw one
guitar center the other day hey i
shouldn't make tarzan i know but it's
awesome but
dude those are shredalicious guitars
back from like warrant and rat days
this poor woman is dating
a 35 year old 11 year old
oh man
folks deal with your trauma sucks and
it's hard deal with it
and if you're a guitar player
put the hammer down
please put it down
put the japanese ibanez down
set it down
you're worth more than that
i do love a good ivan is dude i saw uh
josh adriani in concert he was great he
plays a knife in his that was my first
guitar was a joe satriani ibanez really
were you shredosaurus on it
no what took you astray and led you down
to the world of jingles and sadness and
reverb
not even gonna respond the smiths i
don't know
oh man all right as we wrap up today's
show
let's go with this one the beastie boys
dude
just love it drop in this song called
gratitude it goes like this
good times gone and you miss them what's
gone wrong in your system things they
bounce just like a spalding
what'd you think did you miss your
calling it's so free this kind of
feeling it's like life so appealing when
you've got so much to say it's called
gratitude and that's right
good times gone but you feed it hate's
grown strong you feel you need it just
one thing you do you know
what you think that the world owes you
what's gonna set you free look inside
and you'll see
when you've got so much to say it's
called gratitude and that's right my
boys from brooklyn
gratitude right here on the dr john
delaney show